welcome to another exciting edition of
are you garbage the show where you find
out if your favorite comedians are
classy individuals or absolute trash
now here are your hosts kevin ryan and h
foley
hey
everybody out there and welcome back to
everybody's favorite new podcast this is
are you garbage oh yeah it's a little
show we sit down with your favorite
comedians and we find out if they grow
to be classy or they're just a big old
piece of trash i'm your host dave
trolley coming at you on a beautiful day
down here in aunt tony's basement she's
upstairs knocked out cold oh god yeah
you don't run your mouth in a wah-wah
parking lot i can tell you that all
right my co-host is coming at you from
right next to me he is the ceo of are
you garbage bit of an international
business man himself give it up for kj
kevin james ryan hey gang thanks for
tuning in as always please make sure you
review subscribe on itunes full video
available on youtube and as you know
those numbers are true
then the greatest website of all time uh
www.patreon.com are you garbage check it
out bonus episodes ayg episodes of hard
feelings live streams the whole nine
yards check it out absolutely having a
nice quick shout out to our producer
extraordinaire the magic man makes us
all look good we love them you love them
give it up for t-bone mcscruffin's toby
mcbuttons everybody what's up dudes hey
t-bone never had a whoopee pie but i
didn't watch that joel special best
special of the year
out baby the long-haired lion gang we
couldn't be more excited to have our
incredibly special guest back with us
again again again i think his third or
fourth time here he's [ __ ] family
i think the four club very funny
stand-up comedian podcaster and actor
has a special out right now called this
year's material on youtube as it stands
right now
531 000 views hey all right gang all
jokes aside he is one of the best
standard comedians working today we love
him
give it up for mr joe listen
thank you everybody where are the
cameras
um
i love coming here just for the seinfeld
references
we're back uh you can't put a hawk near
a squirrel
[Laughter]
well once don't you find once you're
with seinfeld people i can't not do it
because i'm doing it anyways i'm already
thinking about it yeah i just say it
when i hang out with non-seinfeld people
they now have to know if i say something
doesn't make any sense just assume it's
seinfeld or goodfellas yeah sure cause
that's another big one you know who i
met the other night just just uh hello
hey how are you i'm henry hi how are you
i'm terry oh miss terry hatcher oh wow
she's a big comedy fan yeah she was at
the seller oh wow yeah she messaged me
during one of the one of the um what do
you call it zoo some zoom
[ __ ] or the seller thing maybe it
was ray ellen somebody had a show and
she messaged me and i was like oh my god
this is so exciting terry actually jerry
hatcher oh yeah she was great in that
jackie charles old girl
that's my last episode
that's right
what's been cooking buddy um not too
much just trying to get this i'm
wrestling the algorithm i'm so afraid of
the algorithm you've got to get the
likes i know it's brutal but it's out
there right now this year's material go
watch it tell a friend there's somebody
you haven't told please tell them i did
this special i'm sweating the algorithm
it's very exciting it's absolutely
fantastic you gotta [ __ ] watch it man
um we i meant that when i said you're
one of the best out there thank you
working we love you uh things are going
fantastic before we get into the patreon
questions i want to do a little
follow-up with you do you feel like
maybe
you're starting to get a little classier
are you starting to do make it a couple
more bucks
a couple years ago very honestly i've
seen your patreon it's doing all right
i'm hoping i mean we're doing okay i'm
making money i'm making more money than
i ever you know i would imagine you got
a pretty nice chunk of change in the
bank great chunk good job
love the church
i know the chunky who has these chunky
wrappers i don't know about chunks
it's a great chunk i don't know what to
do with the chunk i was talking to a guy
the other day
and he was like i'm thinking about
getting into real estate and he said in
the amount of money he had in the bank
and i was like i got way more money than
that
real estate yeah you can get in the real
estate real estate i'll buy your house
call me give me a call
i'll buy a house throw you out i don't
know what to do but you look and the
amount of the house is more money than i
have but i guess you pay money in cash
yeah what do you mean
it's not a pair of shoes joe
all right well i don't know then you put
someone in there is that yeah then you
rent it and then you rent it out in the
hopes that you make more money off the
rent i would do that just buy a house
for yourself and get some equity well i
i want to do that but i have no idea by
the way my wife wants to be near friends
or whatever i just like let's just sit
in the backyard and smoke and look at
stars that's all i want to do is hang
out in the backyard have like a fire pit
of some sort going and just really get
drunk
you were mentioning that outside that
you would obviously you live in a story
we're talking about maybe making them
move out to the burbs i'd like that how
do you picture all that going what what
what would be joe's style would you get
a landscaper would you want to do the
lawn yourself would you put in a pool
i don't know how to do those things i'm
an idiot you don't want to be a [ __ ]
landlord then going and fixing somebody
else's drive i don't know how to pull
the ocean i want to be near the ocean
the ocean heals it heals jerry
the pool doesn't heal you got to fix it
but i don't i want to be like rich when
you have the apartment and the house
that's of course the idea because the
goal because here's the thing i've lived
i worked the road a lot and it shows on
the special this year's material youtube
but i live
i
i live 12 minutes from the airport it's
the thing i won't be able to like part
with if i move to the jersey shore it's
like three and a half days to get to the
it's like oregon trail
laguardia
from astoria it's beautiful it's [ __ ]
it's like it's like it's in your
backyard i literally it takes me 16
minutes it's 30 bucks now will you fly
out of any other airport or you'll just
take a flight even you know you don't
really want will you take an even
earlier flight just because it's
laguardia and are you first class all
the way these days i get upgrade i'm
diamond damn
so how do you get to that's what i was
talking about we're trying to figure out
our way we're almost we're almost so we
just started doing the road this year so
next year will least be silk because
it's about the year before right it's
basically yeah miles flown the year
before yeah we'll probably be silver
with delta they upgrade you for free
when you have this if there's open seats
but they're jammed packed now
these days they're jam but most
like i would say like 75 percent of
flights i get a first gra first class
upgrade every once in a while i'll
spring but now flights are insane and
now it's like 800 bucks to get to
cincinnati i know it's a lot when do you
find that out that they're bumping you
up when you get to the airport sometimes
it's not until you scan yeah sometimes
it's like until everyone's checked
so you think you're going to [ __ ] 38
b and then all of a sudden
yeah so you keep one second
you keep checking it and it'll say
it says the i'm always number one for
the upgrade so like they have the right
they like in the app they'll have like
the hot they'll have the rank of the
people on the flight who's the highest
medallion they have names like a roster
yeah it's like j list yeah really yeah
you're sitting there and you're like oh
you know if you're like 10 you're like
there's no [ __ ] shot you're getting
it wow you have a list of the other
passengers yeah and it literally should
be illegal it literally ranks them yeah
and so it'll say it'll say number of
seats so you're like sometimes it's like
six seats available and you're number
one so you're like guaranteed i'm
getting it wait so you can coach so i'm
on this list too
somewhere on the top tank yeah you know
yeah you're like embarrassing me yeah
you're like you're 38 and 39. you're
like
you're like stony brook on the bcs
rankings yeah
somewhere you have one but your strength
of schedules in the bottom of the class
[ __ ] i don't like people looking at
my name because we pay it's an invasion
of privacy we just bought we were flying
we did denver salt lake and uh
phoenix
three nights back to back to back and on
the first leg to denver we got email hey
do you want to upgrade and i knew we
weren't go well we we had to pay for it
but still only 119 bucks i put me and
him in it wasn't bad um he's a big guy
it was true it was like it changed my
entire
perspective about air travel yeah
i could have done that for three days
sat there well it was like sitting in a
lazy boy the nice thing is getting on
the plane first because i don't check a
bag so the carry-on if you're not gives
me so much anxiety get getting it up
there finding the space when you're the
first one on you just
toss it right up there get a drink and
all the poor people walk by it makes you
feel rich you go like oh i get this i
get how rich people live throw change at
them as they pass but i have such like
class problems i feel like i have to be
like this i got upgraded or a piece of
[ __ ]
my parents make no money i'm sorry it's
just like one of you guys whatever rich
boy i suck
well we got wrecked we were sitting
there we got recognized by a guy walking
by he was like i love the show and i was
like this is the most
yeah but then we also got recognized on
the way back with the guy that was in
the front of the plane as we were
heading towards the rear yeah we were
like the last two guys walking down the
aisle yeah
we'll be by the engine if you need it um
but no it's it's going it's going pretty
good but yeah i would like to have a
house near the ocean ride a bike but you
want to have both you want to be rich
well i i do think that well i think
there is a way where i don't know what
your rent is but it's probably not you
live in australia it's probably not you
know you're probably not paying like
seven grand in my month in rent or
whatever you know i'd say fifteen
hundred two two thousand but we have
this extra bonus thing for 600 so it's
26 all in we have like an office we have
a two bedroom basically okay it's nice
yeah for 2600 you could get something
okay probably where you want at
the shore houses are expensive though
it's crazy i look every couple of weeks
i'm a big i'm big on zero are you
peeking around i go to zillow i pee
like 2.4 you're like it's a shack like
five blocks from the beach it's wild to
me like a house in new jersey near new
york city is like one million bucks i'm
like one million bucks that's crazy a
million dollars i'm like that's like the
joke number yeah it's a million it's a
half number yeah it doesn't even make
sense i know my parents house cost like
11 grand in 1981. but what's it worth
now now there's a house
there's a house in my parents
neighborhood this isn't like doesn't hit
unless you've been there really but like
it's houses went for 440 000 there's no
basement it's like a flat
three bedroom and it's 45 minutes from
boston yeah like there's nothing near
there there's no jobs and it went for
four hundred and forty thousand dollars
that's gotta be a big topic of
conversation at the list house that's
all i know mom my mom knows what that
day down the street what they're doing
they got 450 for it oh there's like it's
you have to as soon as you walk in
you're like you know what the house
across the street went for it's why i
mean it doesn't make any sense but my
parents bought the house in 86 they dr
they kept going south until they could
afford a home yeah from boston yeah yeah
yeah of course and uh so we ended up you
know 40 minutes south pilgrimage it does
i know and there was kyle my mother said
the first night she could hear cows and
she's like this is insane honey wake up
we gotta get out of here like this cows
and now it's like a half a million
dollars crazy man would they ever cash
it in but i don't know where they would
go they would have to move to texas yeah
it's too hot the heat the whole thing
um
sarah my wife's neighborhood for that
amount of money literally you can get
like a five bedroom three bathroom with
a pool
texas is wide open but you got the
scorpions down there though and that is
and that's in like an affluent
neighborhood kingwood which is where she
grew up like a affluent nice like
like like not garbage place i mean
garbage in their own way they're you
know that's how the real estate guy sold
it
[Laughter]
not a lot of okay come on in now the
northeast is a nightmare it's it is it
is crazy i i do we remember i do have
the dream of just [ __ ] getting out
like and anytime i am in a backyard i'm
like what the [ __ ] like last week i was
at my brother's beautiful backyard pool
kids running jumping everybody's
laughing having [ __ ] they got the tv
outside playing the game and i'm like i
gotta get back in the car and drive to
new york for like a 1 45 spot in the
morning i'm like yeah what are we doing
no it's not a way to live life it's
better getting older it's funny because
i'm like i'm such a crazy springsteen
guy and he's like my dad he's like he's
like the most important figure in my
life and i grew up in the suburbs other
than your dad
no beyond the dad
dad stinks
[Laughter]
bruce springsteen you just said bruce
springsteen was more of a dad to you
than your real dad that's trash it's
over for bozo
you're living in the past man
but i'm i'm hung up on some songwriter
from the 60s man
but when i was a kid i grew up in a
small town the little house and i was
like i'm born to run i got to get out
man sure i'm like we were born to run
and now i listen to the same song and
i'm like i gotta get back to you guys
now i'm like this is no way to live yeah
hundred percent i'd like the high rise
i'd be okay in new york with a high rise
high rise would be good doorman the
whole nine yards that's like dorm style
to me like yeah i don't i don't like
sharing
i don't know i think because that's
expensive that shit's like [ __ ] nine
grand a month to being a high rise
that's not good in new york what's the
credit score like i don't i haven't
looked i'm not a credit damage to it in
you did some damage well i never i but
yeah yeah i don't know i haven't looked
i can't look i'm afraid to look what
kind of cards you messing with you might
want to check that out before you go
popping around zillow well i don't know
doesn't it get better it was all medical
bills but can't medical bills not [ __ ]
up medical
no i think just uh
no medical bills can [ __ ] up your credit
i think i don't think they're gonna pay
i don't know but after seven years it
clears
that might be clear i don't know i
haven't i didn't pay i haven't paid
anything
in college i just was like all right i
didn't have money and then i was like
alright i'll start paying these bills
like five years into it and i'm like
what am i doing two years it's [ __ ]
clean slate let's go what credit cards i
don't have any debt i just have one
american express
card that i only use for like rentals
okay
yeah uh wait can you buy all your
why don't you buy the flights on the
credit card you can't like double the
point
i know but i'm an idiot but i have a
business i'm incorporated so i use the
corporate cards when it comes time to do
taxes you just give them the statement
and then they go about that yeah we got
the same guy
he's the best yeah he's great yeah yeah
i have somebody a little down the trough
in those
yeah he uses someone he was i forget the
name i got a junior man on the account
yeah
it's like it's like i don't think so i
forget what it is but it's like harry
levin cpa and he's like harry's talking
about like harry's not talking to you
okay
you got harry's great great grandson i'm
sure he'll move up
you don't have a car i have a car i
bought a car i bought a car during the
pandemic the broom boom
that's a term i heard one time no one
ever uses no it's not no it's not
they're in the pandora people and
they're like this is the vroom boom and
then i was like i like it and i adopted
it started saying it nobody's ever heard
it whatever that's not a thing somewhere
somebody said it oh no it sounds like a
racist error in music
i got caught up in a big room boom
but i got a nissan sentra 2018. nice
just about to click 30 000 miles it was
14.2 when i bought it
so i put about 15k on there that's all
right
any aftermarket products in there neon
lights nas can anything like that nah
none of that stuff i've washed it a
couple of times
guys a real gear head huh
[Laughter]
grease monkey couple vacuums in there
and um no not a big one what kind of air
freshener are you working with no
freshener no
i don't drive it that much i don't know
it still smells pretty new and nice are
you going out and doing the alternate
side parking [ __ ] no i got a garage
so i've spent i spend every once in a
while here and there which is nice you
got a garage how close to the house it's
a couple blocks which is still this new
york nightmare even like when you're
like successful and you're like i got a
i got a spot
you're like all right everybody you guys
ready to go it's like a 15-minute walk
it sucks it's embarrassing
i want to walk out into my driveway i
want to live like a real person it's
like a real boy it's uh yeah johnny usa
over here i like it it's embarrassing i
haven't spent a lot on clothes either
obviously do you eat in the car we eat
in the car i will eat in the car every
once in a while i love a road gig coming
back stopping at mcdonald's and parking
in the parking lot and eating that is
fun
what's your sister what's your
mcdonald's order double quarter pounder
with cheese and ketchup only i don't
like any of this [ __ ] pickles onions no
none of that that's nonsense i hate it
just cheese and ketchup cheese and
ketchup beef cheese and bun i say and
then i handle my own ketchup
don't tell me how much ketchup i don't
trust him and then a fry
and that's it and i'm off coke i've been
off coke for about three years really so
just it's the agua
is that garbage am i all right that's
right
that's all right yeah is there mcnuggets
thrown in there no nugget i've never had
a mcnugget my whole life whoa yeah i'm
i'd eat the same i'm very similar yeah
you've never had it i don't know if i
trust you anymore to be honest with you
i only recently had mcdonald's uh
hashbrowns for the first time that's
something else oh man that right now
this guy's a commies
get the [ __ ] out of here
are you insane we never did breakfast
i'm not gonna let you in texas what are
you guys reading the daily worker
[Laughter]
coffee he's very well ready
holy [ __ ] you never had a [ __ ]
mcdonald's no we never did breakfast
we're not a breakfast fit my fam my
father still doesn't need breakfast my
father's gay
i just watch that one wait what do you
mean your dad doesn't eat breakfast he
doesn't love breakfast he'll have like a
bagel but he waits i'm not i've never
been a big breakfast guy either but so
you get up for school you're going to
school what do you have in the morning i
would do cereal for something i would do
frosted flakes frost flakes of fruit
loops all right that's pretty good what
kind of milk you you banging around with
up there back then it was whole milk
yeah
good stuff exactly straight from the
teeth all right your family wouldn't do
mcdonald's breakfast on a saturday no
you wouldn't get a big breakfast no with
the sausage and the pancakes in the
house
not a tea i'm ridiculous never said hi
never said
this is insane no if we did breakfast
we'd go to maybe like an ihop type of
place or something a big i'd get a big
stack of uh
i never like pancakes i'm a waffle guy
or french toast
french toast pancake stinks
get out of here with pancakes
pancakes at home are delicious i'll give
you the only problem with the waffles at
a place is the shelf life on a waffle of
it being good it's about point three
seconds you gotta get into it quickly
you gotta eat it in the kitchen yeah
yeah yeah i never had a hash brown but i
like filling the cube with the butter
and the syrup and really
getting it in there you know oh it's
autism i gotcha
i got problems
for sure can't let's talk about mint
mobile baby mint man man
you like getting ripped off by the big
guys that's what you like you like
painting like big wireless providers
ripped off fine print no i don't like it
you like overpaying you like getting
[ __ ] bamboozled like a dumbass you do
yourself a favorite idiot yeah take a
page out of your wife's book
who is a mint mobile customer she was 15
a month 15 bucks a month and that was
before it was cool she's a trendsetter
you're sitting there like what's the
catch something something something okay
no
there isn't one mint mobile secret sauce
is the first company to sell the
wireless service online cut out the cost
of retail stores pass those savings
directly onto you cut out the bozo you
choose you choose um you'll probably
lose your number though right uh no yeah
you [ __ ] idiot you keep the same
number keep the same phone for anyone
who hates the phone bill mint mobile for
premium wireless for just 15 beans a
month 15 bucks uh gives you the best
rate uh whether you're less than the
price of a cup of coffee
a 15 cup of coffee is pretty expensive
uh best rate whether you're buying one
for your
whether you're buying one or for a whole
family
uh mint family start at two lines all
plans come with a limited talk test high
speed data uh delivered on the nation's
largest 5g network to get your new
wireless plan for just 15 bucks a month
and get the plan shipped directly to
your door for free go to mintmobile.com
garbage that's mintmobile.com garbage
cut your wireless bill to 15 bucks a
month at midmobile.com garbage do it k.b
let's talk about ladder baby ladder
let's talk about ladder
you know what ladder makes me think of
what's that pal how fragile life is very
it's like it's like a it's like fine
china life is like how we almost got
squashed on the highway in phoenix by
that [ __ ] jerk off in a [ __ ]
pickup truck i know that almost ran us
off the road and if it wasn't for our
uber driver we'd all be dead it could
have been and if we did die we'd be
leaving everybody with nothing because
we got no goddamn term life insurance
yes and ladder can help with that ladder
takes care of what are they dishing out
over there it's first of all it's 100
digital no doctors no needles no
paperwork when you apply for 3 million
in coverage or less we're talking 3
million how can i request a needle
uh just answer a few questions about
your health plan your health in the
application just need a few minutes on
the phone or laptop to apply ladder
smart algorithms work in real time so
you'll find out if you're instantly
approved no hidden fees cancel any time
get a full refund if you change your
mind in the first 30 days that's how
good these people are over there
don't leave stuff
family holding the bag like i'm probably
gonna oh yeah uh finally since life
insurance costs more as you age now's
the time to cross it off your lift so go
to ladderlife.com garbage today to see
if you're instantly approved that's
ladder
l-a-d-d-e-r life
garbage ladderlife.com garbage do it
never had what else haven't you never
had never had a mcnugget
no i mean this is a big mac
not really because i don't like all the
[ __ ] so i do double quarter pounder i
guess you could get a big mac plane sure
if you're a psychopath like a steak
dinner like a new steak yeah big steak
okay steak potato you ever had a frosty
no
mcdonald's literally the only things
i've ever had mcdonald's are a double
quarter pounder or cheeseburger when i
was a kid when i was growing up you know
and french fries no fillet of fish never
had a fillet of fish no i'm eating over
here come on
i love fish but mcdonald's fish okay no
never ice cream i've had like i guess a
soft serve maybe at some point what
about a whopper you have a whopper
i did a whopper but uh normally i just
get a double cheeseburger burger king
too burger king snakes yeah burger king
kind of stuff when i was growing up we
were like that was number one we were
burger king family
and
yeah the hashbrown thing really threw me
yeah sorry but i had one recently i'm
back now
people just turning the special off
right now
can't support what did you guys do for
like a bird it was a birth your birthday
at the list household would you go out
to dinner one time i had a birthday we
went to publishing jesus christ
no wonder why you like springsteen so
much i only had one well we had to have
i mean like people would come over and
you'd have a cake or whatever my mother
would make it people come over they yell
at you and they'd leave but you know
what's funny i never was a cake guy i
got problems i was never a cake guy
poppy's got some problems so they they
stopped making me cake nobody has sung
happy birthday to me i'm not kidding in
about 20 years holy [ __ ] because i never
liked cake so they just don't do it but
i'm like you still don't do it
cake or something like that i have not
had happy birthday sung to me in at
least 20 years wow that's a minimum
shame yeah
i'm a hurt man hurt people hurt people
um you're talking about your parents but
one time we went to papa gino's and that
was fun and we got to make the pizza
that was exciting that was like a fun
birthday and you got to toss it and the
cucumbers
it's not a pizza until it goes in the
oven
do you feel this with your show maybe
it's just because i'm on the show i've
had this with tuesdays with stories i'm
like is anybody getting any of this
because we're just doing science
yeah uh when there's a guest obviously
when like you or normand or a very
seinfeld heavy guest comes donnelly
it'll be you know it'll be you know
shooting quick like this you can't help
it when it's me and him we do it when
it's just me and him we do it a lot as
well yeah i'm always wondering and then
people are like i love the show and i'll
talk about this and people are like
never seen seinfeld you guys rule i'm
always afraid they're going to watch
seinfeld and be like
wait a minute
you guys the [ __ ] hacks just stole
their whole thing joe that is exactly
what happened to me when i started
working on this show oh wow
oh a sci-fi guy then started it and he's
coming he just is like you guys this is
all [ __ ] well what's weird it's just
newman well what's funny is
the show by the way oh funny newman
story but the show now seinfeld is now
30 years old so be like if when we were
kids watching a show they were just
doing yeah they were talking about f
troop or some [ __ ]
um
i got to do a great newman though in
real life the other day that newman
because matt damon was at the stand
and then uh i was so excited i'm a
boston guy he's a boston guy good
hunting to departed the whole thing and
i was like i wanted to like me so much i
did my set went okay and then afterwards
i didn't have the guts to meet him
because i'm a big [ __ ] so i hid in the
back and then the manager came down was
like oh i talked to matt damon he loved
the show and i was like did he mention
me and she goes no he came to see
normand
and then i went norman
i was so happy but there's no seinfeld
people to see it's
his buddy was a big norman fan it was
like told matt damon though you got to
go see mark norman oh how could you um
so they he a couple guys and it looked
like uh the departed he had the hat low
in the corner that's a pretty cool movie
yeah it was to get to that celebrity
status where you do that the hat that is
big great i gotta get a hat yeah
once that special hits a million it
never fits right it's always like a size
too small so your hair kind of sticks
out shanley used to do that move a lot
which was pretty cool that in the
sunglasses it's fun when you see a
celebrity and you're like i i got you i
spotted you yeah especially in new york
you said that used to happen i feel like
pre-painting happened a lot more i guess
i was just out running running the
streets more you would see somebody like
holy [ __ ] what the [ __ ] i asked adam um
what's his name sandler no no adam he's
a comic glenn adam glenn you know him uh
tnt guys tmz and i said how often are we
walking by celebrities and not knowing
he said all the time every day yeah huh
that's what he said
any upgrades to the apartment these days
you get a new couch get anything like
that we got a new couch we got a new
couch and a chair from
ethan allen whoa
sponsor just brought it straight up just
bought it straight up
jeez folks leather what are we talking
no it's velcro whatever thing i don't
know
i don't know much okay what color i
showed up no this is salesman really
bamboozled you talk about garbage this
is embarrassing i went in there we went
into we were watching going to see a
movie we were like we'll go get a couch
across the street beforehand and the guy
said this this couch here is about 35.
this is almost like you're glad to be
handicapped
um he said this is like 3 500 bucks and
i was like oh we're looking more like
three 400 bucks range and the guy was
like you said that i said that and sarah
was like honey what no or not and then
he was like oh
and that was later and then they're both
their reaction i was like wait what does
a couch cost i was like i think i'm
wrong about this and he's like that's
not a couch that's like a used internet
coach and i was like okay forget i said
anything
300 bucks for a cat i didn't i wasn't
thinking i don't know i never bought
anything
so it ended up being like closer to a
couple grand or something they're
expensive yeah they were expensive
what's the what's the chair is it like a
lazy boy nice chair retrainer chair it's
just a
chair
does it go back no it doesn't go back
doesn't do anything is there a sofa bed
in the couch
no okay that's trash i think if you're
buying a sofa sure well that's true sure
yeah we have a spare bedroom
right is there a couch in there
oh yeah we got we got two couches and uh
you have a two bedroom essentially so
what happened was downstairs there was
like an apartment for like the uh mr
fixit guy or whatever super super yeah
but you can't have an official
yeah
this guy wants to be a homeowner
where's the mr fixit guy with this house
where does he live
i mean this the things that look like
silverware the thick stuff i mean tools
yeah that's what i'm looking for
did you ever hear garage silverware let
me tell you colin stewart colin quinn is
one of the great stories sorry i'm just
all over the place but he's got a great
story where he's living this is like
obviously 30 years ago
and uh he's living in his building he
talks to the
mr fix again the guy no no the uh the
owner the landlord and he goes hey colin
could you uh you think you could fix the
sink if you had to
and colin's like uh maybe probably i
guess and he's like all right i'm
looking for a new super for the building
and congo's
frank i'm on saturday night live
and he goes no i know yeah
you want a couple extra bucks hey the
guy's saying work saturdays he's aware
that collins it's not like he didn't
realize he's like no i know you're on
saturday live i want to know if you want
to be a super
uh any jizz so the downstairs it
couldn't be an official apartment
because of fire whatever so there's like
a space there but you can't lend it to
somebody but he's like if you guys it
can be your be part of the house oh yeah
but no one can sleep down there yeah
probably so it's like you can't you have
to go outside of your apartment you got
to leave the apartment go down the
basement but it's nice that's pretty
good that gets you out of the house
you're actually you know it makes it a
little more official yeah sarah goes
down there which is saved us during the
pandemic so she could go to the office
and that way we didn't you know each
other so upstairs is a two is a proper
two bedroom no that's a proper one
bedroom oh it's a one bedroom that's a
one bedroom yeah so where's the extra
bedroom that's the thing is there a bed
down there there's a bed and a bathroom
any thoughts of installing like a fire
pole to get down there in a fun one
viral stairs the original idea was a
spiral staircase and then he was like
it's gonna be a lot more difficult than
i thought and then i was like we could
just have it not that he's like that
would be great let's do that
i could feel him yeah and also i worried
about the heating because you know new
york is it's all pipes it is so i'll get
a plumber on the phone right now
so i just didn't understand how we're
gonna heat and then there'd be a hole in
our house and i was like this isn't
gonna work so we just have to you have
to leave but it's nice is it completely
finished because it sounded nice for a
couple of seconds now i'm not really
sure no it's nice it's a carpet i mean
like the water it's a basement so you
hear water running it's a tile floor
uh it's tile-ish but there's some rugs
like this
i don't know about it it's not terrible
it's not great it's it's not a king bed
down there i would assume no it's a
queen it's our old queen okay that's
good yeah not bad it's good any extra
space let's i mean we're sitting on it
any extra space in new york is there
anything is there an exposed water
heater anywhere down there no no that's
in the closet like i am
that's not bad no it's nice come over
new couch new this knew that pretty good
we got a guy with you guys over some
time we got the we got a little backyard
thing it's like a backyard yeah it's
like not a yard it's cement cement with
a fence or something neighbors hate us
it's really embarrassing time no you
gotta have it it's just like literally
the sun shines on it for like 80 minutes
a day and you sit back there and you
pretend it's nice
and you gotta whisper because there's
like 300 people yeah there's a hundred
windows yeah it's horrendous
you're getting yelled at by your
neighbors like shut up i got a chunk i
got a real chunk over here it's really
terrible basically ron on hershberg
lives upstairs he's a noisy fella it's
hear him stomping around oh my god you
can't believe it no and he's like i
think you're making fun of my weight and
i'm like no that that's you're walking
like he's he's walking like this i'm
like it's not weight doesn't make a
noise it's your gate
gate
he's stomping uh-huh i'm like probably
leads with his heels yeah he's heavy on
the heels you've seen newman run across
i mean he's like he's like on his
tiptoes tippy toe tippy toe um but
anyways yeah he's a noisy fella huh and
you don't sleep with your socks on do
you no okay all right what's good what's
the sleep attire
silly uh box of briefs that's it shorts
or a shirt no shirt no shirt these days
i've been swimming with a shirt over my
head because sarah got some
curtains that are like white so it's
like it's it's like the gates of heaven
and that is a game changer
my wife showed me that the t-shirt over
the eyes it's nice it's it's a nice
touch it's gotta be a soft t-shirt what
are you talking about it's like a hobo
sleeping at a bus station it's not a
t-shirt over your yeah it's nice i'm
telling you why don't you just get one
of those little the mess
no i don't want to be classy yeah
you could tuck the t-shirt in behind
your head it's like a mask so you're
telling me if i walked into your bedroom
and you and your wife were sleeping
sarah would be laying there and you
would be laying there with a t-shirt
over you like you were just killed by a
head wound i look like an iranian
hostage
but you don't tie it around your head
dude no no i drink it you do a drape
yeah yeah
it's nice i'm telling a little bit of
pressure on the eyes helps as well no so
the other day i had a shirt that shrunk
or whatever it was like a michael kors
t-shirt was nice and it triggered and i
was so mad that i just hulk hogan did
and sarah was like mad at me she was
like i would have worn that
and so then she threw it went to throw
it away and i was like don't throw it
away that's not gonna be my drape over
my eyes so i have a torn t-shirt
i have a torn designer t-shirt that i
drape over the side of the bed to put on
my eyes at night oh my god that's my
head cover
let's talk about upside upside upside
upside upside talk about everything
being upside down these days inflation's
through the god damn right wonky you go
to a restaurant you get hit over the
head with a [ __ ] check that can kill
somebody pow
[ __ ] gas prices are through to right
have you been to the pump recently
putin's causing trouble it's chaos out
there but with upside you can help get
yourself some cash back it's an amazing
app that's helping people save money yes
uh to get started just download the free
uh upside app in the app store or on
google play use our promo code garbage
you get five dollars or more cash back
on your first purchase of ten dollars or
more give it money away forgive you look
at this there's no downside to upside am
i all right what are we doing cut me
next you claim an offer for whatever
you're buying on upside uh check-in at
the business pay as usual with a credit
card or debit card and you get paid in
comparison to credit card rewards or
loyalty program you can earn three times
more cash back with upside cash out at
any time right to your bank account
paypal or any gift card boom or amazon
or other brands if you're real tragic
upside users are earning more than put
that right on my johnny rockets card
upsets t-bone from the rafters uh are
using upside users are earning more than
a million dollars every week holy
cannoli that's a lot of stuff
uh that's a lot of onion rings that's
probably have 4.8 star uh 4.8 star
rating on the app store there you go
uh just download for free upside app and
use promo code garbage to get five
dollars or more cash back on your first
purchase of ten dollars or more that's
five dollars or more in cash back and
started your first purchase of ten
dollars or more using promo code garbage
doing the back that i can go back to the
show how do you fall asleep with your
glasses on no never i've never i never
fall asleep i'm a go-to-sleep guy i
never i think following was like a sign
of weakness
[Applause]
it's weird so what do you do i go to bed
i go i'm slumped i'm getting tired
i'm turning in every once in a while if
it's like you know i've really been
whatever or if i take like a tylenol pm
or something
but i'm not a big dozer you never fell
asleep on the couch or anything like
that
i've watched a movie i've drifted but
i'm usually i think
i'm self-conscious about it or something
you know i i think cause it used to be
watching a movie with a t-shirt over his
head yeah wake up your [ __ ] it used to
break my heart when i would want to
watch the game or a movie with my dad
and then you're like do you think you're
sharing something jesus you look over
and he's asleep and it really broke my
heart i would try to wake him up i'm
just resting my eyes that's what he
would say i know my grandfather would
say i'm checking my eyelids for holes
which is a fun one that's pretty good um
and then it's like that now with the
phone like sarah i'm like i think we're
watching like cuckoo's nest or something
and i'm crying i look over and she's
like tick-tock
that's a real sore subject with my with
my girl if we put on a movie and 20
minutes in she sees me looking at my
phone we're supposed to be watching this
together oh i'm her i'm with her on that
one yeah i agree
hmm you have name brand luggage
i do i have the i have two me baby
not bad fancy
that's i think that's as good as it gets
if i'm not mistaken
now does it
roller i assume right yeah does it roll
vertical as well or do you have to dip
it in and drag the vertical roll is
vertical roll
it's huge baby great
yeah all right you're a big park guy too
you like the park i love the park i'm
all about the park which it just shows
you i need to move
all i want the best part of new york
city i think this is a good test if you
think the best part of new york city is
central park you don't belong here
that's a good point i want to be in the
woods the grass i want to roll like a
like a sheep
or whatever sheep's meadow
that's i think that's what made me think
it
any clocks in your house that are wrong
yes
the stove but it's not my
fault not it's the mr fix it guys i
think the stove the stove sucks and then
the microwave doesn't work we have a
stove and microwave sounds like a
junkyard
it's bad again it's this new york life
you just go all right i guess my food
doesn't work at all it worked no the
microwave works just the clock doesn't
work you got an air fryer
i don't know what that is
i think maybe sarah she does the cooking
i do the ubereats
i know you guys i know you guys have a
weird thing with the food she makes
dinner and you don't eat it yeah i don't
know how you get away with that i would
never be able to get away yeah it's a
problem it's a thing but i'm just i like
ubereats and this is where i spend all
my money this is why i can't have a
house i spend like 300 bucks a week on
ubereats how do you coordinate that like
all right dinner's almost done make your
order and then you eat together we
rarely
coordinate meals
that's why we're gonna get divorced i'm
just as i'm saying it out loud i'm like
she eats early i eat late and it just
everything in the basement all the time
yeah yeah sometimes got our own entrance
it's not looking great we ate together
occasionally we'll go out oh god
do you know what the term bogo stands
for bogo
know
oh yes i just thought of it buy one get
one yeah that's a true mark of a dirtbag
yeah but it took me some thinking i
didn't know it right now
but i'm also good at that i'm good at uh
acronyms yes i'm good at figuring out
acronyms i think you're not a shopper
though are you you don't go out and just
shop and
get things that you don't need no rarely
i don't buy that's when i feel good
because i spend a lot of money on
ubereats and uber ubers to cars but um
and i'll i'll get nice tickets to things
and stuff but i don't spend on things
i'm wearing the same old navy sweatshirt
i don't buy shoes or anything this might
be a little inside baseball but what are
you ordering from over there in the
story i'm curious
um taste of italy is my new spot have
you ever heard of it i don't even know
where it is because uber eats it's very
good great chicken parm right next to my
apartment no kidding
my pizza place oh wow the place right
next door yep they do italian
specialties their pizza is great yeah i
get the chicken parm it's massive yeah i
like their pizza better than belluci's i
love juice pot love tastes of italy i'll
do that a lot and then
where else do i order petey's burgers
lately this is you want to talk garbage
i've been getting mcdonald's delivered
and it's like a block for me yeah
mcdonald's delivery one on 31st yeah
yeah the one on 21st street is a top
shelf organization oh really i don't
know if that's a flagship store or
whatever but they they're fantastic no
kidding i think better than the 31st
street one wow i had to know all right
uh you said you liked like tickets to
events have zero an event you've been
too recently that you really enjoyed
since things have opened up more
anything
what was the first one you went to as
things have come back first one back i
go to the see here now festival every
year asbury park i went to that this
past year that was nice that was a big
event
trying to think of where i've been i
just went to the buffalo sabres game
that was whatever i went to the bruins
game i went to two red sox games
yeah i spent all my money on what's the
food move at a hockey game
i'm all hot dog french fries hot dog
just ketchup french fries just ketchup
can't go
crazy
up the wrong
up the middle for a basement
you're trying to pull the ball you're
into a double play you know what i mean
not showing off not falling behind
good stuff do you know how to use
chopsticks no
yeah
i'll do an alien but uh no no idea i
would imagine you're you don't step out
of the box cuisine wise do you like
chinese food i like i like general style
white rice and i'll put some of the
ketchup on it
[Laughter]
did you guys call it irish marinara that
was the term we had uh
um it always gets a laugh
hey hit me the irish marinara was like
ah yeah that is uh
classic bill um
uh indian food indian food i had indian
food once in london oh my god you sound
like my mom jesus christ no i like spicy
george likes his chicken [ __ ] i do
like spicy going to the new pakistani
place on 43rd street um you're not
wearing that are you maybe i've had it
twice because i will eat if i'm in a
situation where we're eating if it's up
to me we're getting burgers or pizza
chicken pie or whatever but when i
travel i've traveled to a lot of yeah in
germany yeah a little schnitzel i'll
have some schnitz
whatever the [ __ ] goat [ __ ] they gave me
or whatever i'll do it if i have to sure
because i'd rather not be embarrassed
well that's i'm as i'm also a very picky
eater and that's how i found myself
trying new things is because
you don't want to seem like a [ __ ]
idiot or cause like a scene of like oh
well kevin or kevin doesn't like that
yeah i'm just very like [ __ ] just
give me the bread and don't look don't
make eye contact
i don't know if i told the story before
i went to peru and years ago and it was
like we hiked the salkin thai trail and
it was like every day we were hiking
mile like in the jungle in machu picchu
yeah to machu picchu you did yeah damn
it was amazing and then we had like
sherpas who carried our [ __ ] and set up
camp and they cooked for us and i
literally bought like military meals
ready to eat spaghetti and meatballs mac
and cheese because i was so nervous can
you heat up my velveeta for me and the
first day i like started to take it out
and i was like
yeah and i just had to eat whatever and
it was great and i got through it yeah
but it felt weird because they were like
peruvian they didn't even know what the
[ __ ] i was talking about it was like mac
and cheese
you make some
meatballs milk with water in a pinch you
did make mac and cheese the other day
but it was oh you tagged it it was craft
deluxe
but i did walk i walk to the grocery
store buy that don't bring any bags i
buy it and carry it back like a book
yeah and then make and i eat the whole
thing you use milk or use water
i what do you mean in the cheat in the
thing oh that's the one that's no ass
like no that's just like the liquidy
cheese that's like the velveeta oh yeah
that's as a kid that was the best
that's the best meal i every day i think
about kevin mcallister never got to eat
his mac and cheese that looked delicious
and it looks so perfect freezing cold
glass of milk it looks so good there's
no way i would have walked away from
that table i didn't care what time it
was
[Laughter]
uh but no i love a good box of mac and
cheese the pizza also look really good
little nero's look like they put out a
price oh yeah it's a nice buy yeah nice
tip too
lady threw it down all right let's get
into some cues here okay as you know
when you sign up for your patreon we ask
him on the air we happen to have mr joe
list in the building he'll be answering
these questions again if you haven't
seen it if you don't know about it do
yourself a [ __ ] favor this year's
material on youtube check it out thank
you keller pro broadcaster right there
comment that was nice the mid plug yeah
right cut to the weather
yeah also it's big go to his page and
share the clips and like with your
friends yeah the dm the
the the promo clips work the rhythm a
little bit people love the clips
um all right speaking of
let's see here speaking of sporting
events this is from nickel has anyone in
your family ever gotten engaged at a
professional sports event
oh no no
but man i always wish the person would
say no i've thought about you feel like
you're creating that and saying no no
the respectable you say yes and then
later on in the parking lot like i'm not
married yeah yeah and i always think the
woman's not as into the sport as the guy
never of course nevertheless
have you ever been on a kiss cam
ooh
no i haven't i've never been on the kiss
camp but i have i feel like you're a guy
who really tries to get on the megatron
i have been the jumbo start doing the
floss or whatever that dance got the
shirt off going do do that and i have
been yeah oh look at this guy going for
broke over there i have been at a bruins
playoffs game in the 90s i was in high
school and i had let's get rowdy boston
which the photos on instagram they i
they had it where the camera guy was on
my chest so the big screen was just my
torso and that was very exciting that
was like quite a thrill yeah going to
school tell the boys about it that was
really
it was pretty cool so yeah i try to go
for the jumbo tron
there's a big thing now of when kids get
on uh not kids like you know
dudes or in their 20s or whatever they
do they there's like now a thing where
they do the double dicks like they they
let it get on them and they're like yeah
go team
and then just start
the second time yeah
take that jumbotron what would you say
is the classiest thing you've ever done
whether it was like a super expensive
restaurant like if you've been on you've
been on a private plane before right
many times yeah okay yeah that's pretty
good yeah pretty good i mean i was a
guest still but yeah you're there pretty
cool i've done that um
i've picked up a check for a rich person
that feels pretty cool how much was the
check it was like uh maybe 150 bucks
something like that is a gesture sure
kind of nice
and uh i i paid for our family's
vacation house one year that's big that
fell
that was before i really had all of the
lifts all the whole gang the whole
kitten caboodle that's pretty nice where
was that at in maine okay so it was like
800 bucks but still
but
now it was my aunt's place um did you
ever mention the price to them or was
there like uh are you a facetime are
they was there guilt of you shouldn't
done you shouldn't have done this no i
think it was like yeah that's right
how many people know how much you paid
for the couch
um that made the trade you're not you're
not telling people i don't know 3500 for
a nice couch that's pretty good yeah no
i don't think so i'd be opening with
that you kidding me now do they deliver
the couch they deliver the couch but
they wouldn't take the old couch so that
was the whole thing how much did you tip
the delivery guys i gave them 40 bucks
it was two guys and i gave them 40 bucks
20 that's good great nice good i love a
good tip you wouldn't take it too that's
[ __ ] how did you get in there
me and steve rogers wonderful comedian
with a big dick we uh unscrewed oh i
unscrewed the thing and then we carried
it out and left it out on the side and
then like four hours later i came out
there was a lady literally sitting on it
making a phone call
not a homeless lady just like a lady
that was like oh sweet a couch
all right
um
let's see here
this is from kevin james ryan gosling
nice uh you ever scrape the mold off
food and consider it edible again oh no
i cut it off of bread or something no
not to throw under the bus she's not
here to defend herself
i could see sarah doing that sarah does
that sarah will eat like
she'll pull out milk and just want to
smell it and be like ah and then pour it
i'm just it's wild i'm a no a risk
reward guy well you know and i don't
know if this is true but i it's been
going around on that their uh tick tock
or instagram or like meme or something
where
a milk container has a cutout like a
circle on the side like an indent yes
and that is that's functional once that
pops out that tells you it's no longer
good oh
i don't know if that's true or not so
don't give it a whirl but yeah like if
that pops out that means it's no longer
good oh wow i never heard that yeah now
you can roll the dice i've definitely
left it in my fridge
long enough to where that's been popped
out and i go oh yeah you don't yeah
that's no bueno well sarah yesterday the
other day she hadn't made eggs in a
while but she was like ah try to save
actually she's one of these save people
whatever we know we know the
cheese story i'll just go re-buy she
cracked the egg and it came out black
and smelled like [ __ ] she said she
almost barfed
and like the whole house stunk because
it was like four months old like black
[ __ ] came out of an egg
jesus black what are you witches what
the hell i don't know
i don't i don't even know how
but yeah she tries to save [ __ ] i just
go oh i'll re-buy yeah i'm the same my
wife
straightened out
bitties not a bad onion ring over there
petey's bro not an onion ring guys yeah
what this guy had just had a hash brown
for mcdonald's french fry i'm a french
fries all the way not an onion ring guy
no what about a mozzarella stick love a
stick i'll shove a mozzarella stick
right up my house
i love a hot stick
are you kidding where's your do you have
a place where you're like that's my
favorite mozzarella a place that really
does them well even from childhood or
now where you're like that was a classic
mozzarella tough to say i do get the
taste of italy ones they're kind of
whatever i hard to think of a much
realistic that's really amazing there
was this place that used to do triangle
ones
that's too fancy they were [ __ ]
phenomenal
friday's does the square ones i believe
like the rectangle ones they're all
right yeah those are okay i'll give you
that yeah it's hard to say i know the
best meatball mama santas have we talked
about mama santas
mama santa's in cleveland if you guys
ever go you got to go to little italy
mama santa's family owned and operated
they make the pasta in the back
mama santa's little italy cleveland go
okay it rules
i took bobby kelly there louis ck
they're loving it yeah yeah all right
we'll have to check this out i have to
do that then that seems to know a
meatball i feel like you guys didn't
believe me until i mentioned two fat
guys
that's when he was like i'm listening
with that
it's like certified right there i'm like
oh interesting okay bobby kelly's stamp
of approval i'm in it's good stuff if
bobby says it's good it's got to be good
sure i don't know i also don't like it
you don't take our guess word for that
you know what i mean yeah this guy's
been around the block no he's traveled
the world
mcdonald's in norway get the [ __ ] out of
here whale they got good mcdonald's is
it just fat or is there actual meat in
there i don't know i think it was it's
very how'd you have it dark and um in a
finger what do you have it was just uh i
don't know it was a piece of whale and i
tried it because i wanted to say hey
whale but it was pretty gross
and then i went back and um i was with
another comic um
dino i don't know how to say his last
name he wrote for the dana carvey show
it's greek like mock-up
or something but he had it he ordered it
as a meal and he's like this is the
worst thing i've ever had yeah
so don't eat whale that's kind of crazy
yeah yikes you're not a seafood guy
generally are you i like you
i like massachusetts
not an oyster guy fish and chips fish
and chips i love saturn i went to wales
we ate fish and chips exclusively every
day
and uh i love this i like salmon okay
yeah i like a fish but sushi disgusting
uh whatever the [ __ ]
just mentioned
oysters i hate you won't do sushi now i
tried sushi once i almost threw it up it
was very embarrassing because the guy
was standing over me being like this is
the best
and uh i can't do it either i was like
doing this and he's like what is this i
can't do accents just pretty much
bringing a double quarter pounder with
cheese [ __ ] zip it
um this one's from paulie walnuts never
had a question read have you ever been i
feel this is very in your wheelhouse
have you ever been tubing down a river
with beers well i know you're sober now
absolutely yes the merrimack river up in
new hampshire so much fun dude yeah a
lot of we do ocean tubing too my family
we still on the boat like on the back
yeah yeah that gets like it's who's
driving the boat yeah my uncle who's
having a lot of beers
i've gotten whipped off one of those in
the sku kill river and thought i was
gonna be [ __ ] dead meat it's fine
i've gone with sarah and you go as a
pair and you can bury them by diving off
the side cause it throws the weight off
yeah it's fun so like in the middle of
it i go by honey and i just
then she's like
i've seen it where it it it goes up in
the air they have those now that have
like wings kind of get the [ __ ] out of
here yeah
yeah no that's fun good fun any other
water sports skiing water skiing or
anything i tried water skiing when i was
like 13 years old again on my uncle's
boat and my instinct
i wrecked immediately i didn't know how
to do it i couldn't do it
you need but i didn't think to let go
because that seems counterintuitive
uh-huh like that's where my family is i
held on and i literally was like getting
dragged for like talking about [ __ ]
abandonment issues it was bad i just got
so much water and then they leave me i
thought it just seemed like i don't want
the boat to keep going of course so it
was it was very traumatic it was like
burt reynolds
i'm getting a lot of trauma just talking
about these things my dad falling asleep
uh the
water skiing
she touched my leg
this one's from mike first time long
time uh
ever buy a gift or the card on the way
to a party
oh like mother's day or a birthday or so
you stop at the cvs absolutely i've done
that and worse than that bobby kelly's
son had a birthday party years ago
and i went with soder and soda had
bought two gifts and i just took one of
his that's that's a dirtbag move which
i've done i'll throw my name on that
type thing but to be fair we went on the
podcast later and to really sing
i guess as a compliment to both soda and
i
i came clean
and soda was like don't do it what are
you doing so soda is a good sodas soda's
a good guy soda is a very nice man and i
just had a guilty conscience but so yeah
i've done that for sure when you do the
i've done the on my way to a kid's party
bought the toy at the pharmacy yeah you
just slim you gotta you're they really
they really know yeah they really yeah
it's really really whack but the card on
the way i think is smart i've never
bought a card previous and also that's
what you do you what why am i going to
buy a card bring it upstairs to the
house then
fill it out bring it back down remember
that grab a card on the way what are we
doing yeah card in the way is good it's
a lot of gift card if i get you a gift
card that was i didn't put any thought
yeah
you have nieces and nephews yeah you do
mm-hmm what's what do you guys usually
would you get them for christmas
oh good question oh i got uh my my
nephew was 13. i got tickets to the sox
game which is a punishment if you're 13.
because he grew up on tick-tock he's
sitting at the baseball game being like
this is the worst thing yeah see that
being tall nine-hour baseball he just
hated it and then my niece i'm taking to
see brandy carlisle she's 16. so that's
like a nice rock
brandi carlos the experience this is a
good is good no that's belinda carlos oh
okay brandi carlisle is a rock and roll
slide it does a little bit of country
now it's a god it's a man it's a woman
oh it's a woman okay he's big on the
tickets i love a ticket that's a good
experience you gotta get the experience
now when you give them the tickets do
you are you actually giving them the
tickets or are you saying email or
something no there's
so literally i'm like here's your
christmas gift on this date we're going
to this thing and they're like okay yeah
that's a bummer it sucks
you gotta do something put something in
the shoe box you're not a cash guy you
give them cash yeah no cash
i should give them cash cash kids like
cash at weddings though right
are you a gift guy
i don't care no i do cash i haven't been
to a
there's no so many degenerate [ __ ]
everyone i know is either married or not
close to getting married at your wedding
do you have any standout envelopes
you don't have to name names i'm trying
to think
no louis didn't get me a gift he took me
he took me to paul mccartney but sarah
didn't get to go
so she got nothing this guy's all right
yeah and we've met we've met mccartney
hung out with him met springsteen sarah
got nothing
um and then um no envelopes
drinking sour milk and eating black eggs
you're hanging with the yeah i'm trying
to think of who else i mean there was a
decent cash and then colin quinn
couldn't make it to my wedding he gave
me
a car he sent a car with cash and then
he got married the next summer and i
gave him back the exact same amount of
cash yeah so we just traded off cash
what it's like um
donnie bresco
um what uh
so you say you know
always get you know we're acquaintances
we're not you know not best friends
fully invite you to his wedding sure you
and sarah
it's in queens there's no big travel
what are you giving them 300
is that something that's good that's not
good that's something 370 good all right
300. that's pretty good that's good
ketchup waiting on the table
a couple
how did i miss it come on
i imagine you're a good time at a
wedding i can see you with a tie
can you do the worm i can't do the worm
but i do my own version of the worm i'll
do a jump i do it angus young where
you're running the circle and then
someone jumped you mean the curly what's
the curl is on the ground
yeah i guess so yeah i do a lot of that
i do a lot of dancing i can really rip
when sarah and i got married the dj
commented he's like we've never seen a
bride and groom dance this much we never
stopped dancing we just danced the whole
night because we didn't want to talk to
anybody can you do the macarena i'll do
a macarena you don't you know the moves
i think so yeah it's kind of uh one
magnitude something like that
but okay
you said you would do a jump what kind
of jump are we talking like rock and
roll kick a leg a lot of jumping a lot i
feel like you're a big air guitar guy
which isn't good huge academy
[Laughter]
i mean i really get after it do you hit
the sprinkler with the thing oh i never
thought of that i'll do the shopping
cart
i'm at a good time the fish out of water
that's big
should i was doing the mashed potato
no we danced the night away i mean we
had a good time limbo you limbo
i suppose you can limbo
what's that from that's the swivel i
suppose it gets
one of those
[Laughter]
what kind of cake did you have at your
wedding i don't even know because you
don't like cake vanilla i like cake now
i've i've i've grown into a cake man
never had a whoopie pie that's what you
you said that that's been burning yeah
we talked about yeah whoopie pie guy
i've heard of corduroy
i didn't know chocolate
that there was just chocolate chip ice
cream oh that's right yeah
that's what you like yes i love a
chocolate chip guys i think we had some
kind of vanilla cake white cake thing
did you save the top of it
no i don't think there was a top really
we didn't do we didn't do a lot of
traditional things and we didn't shove
cake into each other we never got that
we thought that was weird i think that's
pretty trashy you know what they do now
is
if it's a little kid's birthday they'll
smash his head into the cake oh you
haven't seen those videos on instagram
no i haven't oh it's gotta be
traumatizing yeah i don't like that we
didn't it feels weird because like
i guess when we were older her parents
are there either parents are british and
maybe that's part of it but i'm like i
can't be smashing cake they're like
classy people yeah
i mean her parents do their parents live
in england no no they've
immigrated or immigrated emigrated they
emigrated from came over yeah they came
over here everyone always complains
about english food and it sounds like
you would [ __ ] love it
yeah those fish and chips but that's
what i always think about like london
people like you got to have the indian
food i'm like how sad that your nation's
food is a different nation
wow that's
kind of uh kind of their whole thing
everything is taken from other places
around the world yeah i suppose so
imperialism or whatever
[Laughter]
well whatever a lot of damage done what
can you do sorry folks it's a new day
huh start fresh i didn't do nothing
it was the 80s david had a [ __ ]
goddamn birthday it's not his fault
[Laughter]
uh let's do uh let's do two more here
and we gotta wrap it up
um this one this is from matt i haven't
had a question right have you or anyone
you know ever hung like girls lace or
like the garter in the rear-view mirror
did sarah have a garter belt did you
guys do that no no guard are we the best
man takes it off no we didn't do any of
that ever have you ever been a man
doesn't take it off what do you think he
does
i think right now the groom takes it off
the best man's putting his hands
someone's going to talk to miami my aunt
cindy yeah
what are you crazy no i think he gets up
under the dress right yeah t-bone best
friend's not getting under my wife's
dress you're on your mind 100 it's
definitely the best man that does it
it's not the groom
why would that be and then the the
the maid of honor gives a lap dance to
the groom
what are you talking about
the usher blows the flower girl i'm like
what are you talking about no no it's
supposed to be the crew man
that's it's her wedding day it's a
sacred day oh god damn it have the
[ __ ] best man go up the thing you
can't have that's uncle charlie taking
it off with his teeth what are you doing
that's like
that's like a cuckold wedding
hey i don't know whatever you guys are
into joe joe's tied up in the corner no
we did no garter belt no church we
didn't do it okay you threw the boqueto
right we didn't do a bouquet throw and
um the first dance we had a group dance
we had uh gree you're the one that i
watched
yeah which one you're the one that i
want from greece and everybody dance
joe's on the hood of a car because we
don't want to do the whole thing we're
just out there yeah
but we didn't eat yeah we didn't do that
you didn't do an entrance did you with
the the bridal the the party's entrance
they come in and like
give it up for mars norman
no we just had um it was just me and uh
my best man best buddy were up the front
bobby kelly married us uh
garbage um
and then sarah walker was her dad
and that was it and then we just walked
everyone walked over to the thing okay
all right and we did all one spot it was
all in the that's the best all just
central locations i love that
i'm getting emotional here that was the
best day of my life
kid's an actor ladies and gentlemen
ladies and gentlemen mr joe list this
year's material out on youtube yes a lot
of big things coming up tuesdays with
stories of course your house in the
works maybe i want i hope we'll see who
knows you might see him down there at
the beach i love that would you walk the
beach are you a body like a body surf
kind of guy i feel no i'm just like a
hangout in the where the in the breakers
and get hit and go ah and jump around
it's very spiritual it heals i'm a big
ocean guy myself what about a metal
detector could you ever see yourself
trolling the beaches with a metal
detector no but we were just in aruba
sarah and i with a rubber ray ellen and
a girl lost her ring and she flagged
down the the you know guy the guy and he
found it that would be the biggest
moment that guy was [ __ ] it was big
and she was like 22 and hot like tits
out the whole thing and she was like
thank you and you can see he was like
you're like crispin glover
you could tell it was one of those
things where she was like i owe you and
he was like oh god oh my god yeah
chopping up over you have a garter belt
on you
you want to get married anything you
want the folks out there to know uh
this is coming out next
all my dates i'm coming to nashville
toronto vancouver san francisco uh a
bunch of them they're all my website
finally updated my site
comedianjoelist.com and this year's
material on youtube please like share
comment all that [ __ ] 100 most of you
know joe list if you don't you're an
idiot check out the [ __ ] special he's
one of the best great and we'll see you
guys next week we love you peace peace